I wanted to talk about this for a second
we have all been through the wringer
these past few months and today is a
it's a really strange day yes very
strange day half the country is really
happy half the country somewhere between
despondent and furious and you may not
notice about me or you may I'm a history
buff I love American history and I was
struck by one thought today we have been
here before we have had bitter angry
elections for 200 years
whether it was Jefferson versus burr
Adams versus Jackson Lincoln versus
Douglas alien versus Predator
I threw that in I'm trying to keep it
light the point is the point is the
Israelis are like he's too about it
the point is this is our thing okay and
the optimist in me chooses today to be
happy that we have fair and free
elections at all I think it's an amazing
thing
I really do in the last I do in the last
in the last couple of years I've
traveled to a bunch of countries Cuba
Armenia the Middle East where the people
would give anything anything to have our
system in America we get to pick who's
going to ruin our country it's up to us
we get to choose and it's a privilege
now I was watching and you saw this too
I'm sure I was watching President Obama
and Hillary Clinton speak today about a
peaceful transfer of power and it gave
me chills
now today Americans have the right to
feel happy angry pessimistic optimistic
but everybody should feel grateful that
we get to vote and if we don't get our
way we have the chance to try again it
is a beautiful thing
Winston Churchill one of my favorite
people Winston Churchill once said
democracy is the worst form of
government except for all those other
forms that have been tried
[Applause]
yeah Winston Churchill also said when
healing a divided nation always resort
to cheap visual comedy now with that in
mind let's bring out an old friend of
ours this is silly and completely
pointless but he always cheers me up the
really tall dachshund let's get the
really tall box in there
[Applause]
mr. picture
[Applause]
who just makes me I love his posture I
love everything about the really tall
dachshund and I feel better already
you